Nous utilisons ces fonctions pour perdre une habitude,
pour inhiber nos impulsions ou faire des projets.
On remarque son existence quand les choses tournent mal.
Avez-vous déjà versé par mégarde du jus d'orange sur vos céréales ?
(Rires)
Ou commencé à naviguer sur Facebook
et vous apercevoir que vous avez raté une réunion ?
(Rires)
Ou, chose familière s'il en est :
vous avez prévu de passer au supermarché sur le trajet du retour
et conduit jusque chez vous en pilote automatique ?
(Rires)
Ça arrive à tout le monde.
On appelle souvent ça de la distraction,
mais il s'agit en réalité
d'une défaillance de nos fonctions exécutives.
Nous les utilisons quotidiennement dans tous les aspects de notre vie.
Les 30 dernières années,
les chercheurs ont découvert que ça prédit plein de choses positives
dans l'enfance et plus tard,
les compétences sociales, la réussite académique,
la santé mentale et physique,
gagner de la vie, épargner
et même ne jamais aller en prison.
Super, n'est-ce pas ?
Ce n'est donc pas mystérieux
que des chercheurs comme moi soient curieux de les comprendre
et de trouver un moyen de les améliorer.
Récemment, les fonctions exécutives sont devenues un mot à la mode
du développement personnel.
On croit possible de les améliorer avec des applis d'exercices mentaux,
des jeux vidéo
ou en les entraînant de manière spécifique comme en jouant aux échecs.
Les chercheurs essaient de les entraîner dans leur labo,
mus par l'espoir de l'améliorer avec d'autres éléments liés,
l'intelligence, par exemple.
Je suis ici pour vous dire
que cette idée sur les fonctions exécutives est erronée.
L'exercice mental ne va pas améliorer les fonctions exécutives au sens général,
car cela implique de s'exercer de manière pointue,
en dehors des contextes de la vraie vie où nous les employons.
On peut donc maîtriser une fonction exécutive sur notre appli,
mais ça ne vous empêchera pas
de verser du jus d'orange sur vos céréales.
(Rires)
Pour améliorer vos fonctions exécutives
afin que cela influence votre vie,
vous devez comprendre en quoi le contexte les influence.
Je vais clarifier cela.
Au labo, nous avons une expérience très performante
pour mesurer les fonctions exécutives des enfants.
C'est l'épreuve de tri de cartes selon leur variation dimensionnelle, DCCS.
Dans cette épreuve, les enfants doivent trier les cartes selon une dimension,
leur forme par exemple,
de manière répétitive pour créer une habitude.
Ensuite, on leur demande de trier les mêmes cartes
selon un autre critère,
la couleur, par exemple.
Pour les jeunes enfants, c'est difficile.
Des enfants de 3 ou 4 ans continueront de trier les cartes selon leur habitude,
peu importe le nombre de fois où vous direz ce qu'ils doivent faire.
(Vidéo) Femme : les cartes bleues, tu les mets ici, les rouges, là-bas.
Voici une bleue.
Bien. Maintenant, on va jouer à un autre jeu.
On ne joue plus avec les couleurs.
On va jouer avec les formes.
Dans le jeu des formes,
toutes les étoiles vont ici, et les camions vont là, d'accord ?
Les étoiles ici, les camions là.
Où mets-tu les étoiles ?
Où mets-tu les camions ?
Très bien.
OK, les étoiles ici, les camions, par là.
Voici un camion.
(Rires)
Les étoiles ici, les camions là.
Voici une étoile.
(Rires)
SB : C'est absolument irrésistible.
C'est évident quand elle n'utilise pas ses fonctions exécutives.
Mais il y a un os :
on pourrait l'entraîner à cette tâche et à d'autres tâches similaires,
elle finirait par s'améliorer.
Mais cela signifie-t-il
qu'elle aura amélioré ses fonctions exécutives en dehors du labo ?
Non, car dans le vrai monde, elle aura besoin de les employer
pour faire bien plus de choses que passer des formes aux couleurs.
Elle devra passer de l'addition à la multiplication,
du jeu au rangement
ou de penser à ses propres sentiments en pensant à son amie.
La réussite dans des situations réelles dépend de facteurs
tels que la motivation ou ce que font vos pairs.
Ça dépend aussi des stratégies d'exécution que vous mettez en place
quand vous utilisez vos fonctions exécutives dans une situation donnée.
En fait, le contexte est très important.
Voici un exemple issu de mes recherches.
J'ai fait passer le test classique de la guimauve à un groupe d'enfants.
Ce test mesure la gratification différée
mais ceci fait aussi appel à des fonctions exécutives développées.
Vous connaissez peut-être ce test.
Il donne un choix aux enfants.
Ils peuvent manger une guimauve maintenant
ou attendre pendant que je vais dans une autre pièce
chercher d'autres guimauves.
Dans ce cas, ils peuvent en manger deux.
La plupart des enfants veulent manger la deuxième guimauve.
Mais la question est de savoir combien de temps ils sont capables d'attendre.
(Rires)
J'ai ajouté un petit élément pour observer l'impact du contexte.
J'ai expliqué aux enfants qu'ils font partie d'un groupe,
le groupe vert par exemple,
et je leur ai offert un T-shirt vert.
J'ai dit au groupe vert : « Votre groupe a patienté pour obtenir deux guimauves
mais pas l'autre groupe,
ceux qui sont en orange. »
Ou bien, j'ai dit l'inverse :
« Votre groupe n'a pas patienté pour deux guimauves
mais l'autre groupe l'a fait. »
Après ça, je laissais les enfants seuls
et j'observais avec une caméra combien de temps ils allaient attendre.
(Rires)
J'ai découvert que les enfants convaincus
que leur groupe avait attendu pour deux guimauves,
étaient plus susceptibles d'attendre.
Ils étaient donc influencés par des pairs qu'ils n'avaient jamais rencontrés.
(Rires)
C'est plutôt cool, non ?
Sur la base de ces résultats, je ne savais toujours pas
s'ils imitaient leur groupe simplement ou s'il se passait quelque chose d'autre.
J'ai donc réuni davantage d'enfants.
Après le test de la guimauve, je leur ai montré des photos de deux enfants
en leur disant : « Un des deux enfants aime bien obtenir les choses directement,
des biscuits ou des autocollants.
Mais l'autre enfant préfère attendre
pour obtenir un plus grand nombre de ces choses. »
Ensuite, je leur demande :
« Quel enfant préférez-vous
et avec lequel voudriez-vous jouer ? »
J'ai découvert que les enfants convaincus que leur groupe attendait
avaient tendance à préférer les enfants qui préféraient attendre.
En apprenant le comportement de leur groupe,
ils accordaient plus de valeur à l'attente.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Ces enfants utilisaient leurs fonctions exécutives
pour générer des stratégies qui les encourageraient à attendre,
comme s'asseoir sur leurs mains, détourner le regard de la guimauve
ou encore chanter pour se distraire.
(Rires)
Ceci met en évidence l'influence du contexte.
Ces enfants n'avaient pas des fonctions exécutives meilleures ou moins bonnes.
C'est le contexte qui leur a permis de mieux les exploiter.
Quelles sont les implications pour vous et vos enfants ?
Imaginez que vous vouliez apprendre l'espagnol.
Vous pourriez modifier votre contexte
et vous entourer d'autres personnes qui souhaitent aussi l'apprendre,
et ce serait encore mieux si ce sont des personnes que vous appréciez.
Ainsi, vous serez plus motivé pour utiliser vos fonctions exécutives.
Vous pourriez vouloir aider votre enfant à mieux réussir ses devoirs de maths.
Vous pourriez lui enseigner des stratégies pour exploiter ses fonctions exécutives
dans ce contexte précis,
éteindre son téléphone avant de commencer à étudier
ou prévoir une récompense après une heure d'étude.
Ne pensez pas que le contexte est tout.
Les fonctions exécutives sont complexes et modelées par de nombreux facteurs.
Mais j'aimerais que vous vous souveniez
que si vous souhaitez vraiment les améliorer
dans certains aspects de votre vie,
n'espérez pas de solution miracle.
Réfléchissez au contexte,
comment vous pouvez rendre vos objectifs plus importants à vos yeux
et comment mettre en place des stratégies
pour vous aider dans cette situation précise.
Je pense que les anciens Grecs l'avaient compris en affirmant :
« Connais-toi toi-même. »
Et c'est en partie lié à la compréhension
de l'influence du contexte sur nos comportements
et comment utiliser ce savoir pour nous améliorer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)